In this section, we will go over the Propagate changes from Scene to DNA script.
This script allows us to save the deltas between the current and new vertex and joint positions of meshes,
and then saves those changes to the DNA file.
We will look at two simple use case scenarios using this script to edit the neutral pose.
In the first scenario, we will make some simple changes to the vertex positions,
and in the second scenario, we will make some minor modeling changes using the joints and skin clusters.
So, let's jump into Maya and begin by taking a look at the script and going over the workflow.
Inside of Maya, I have taken the Propagate changes from Scene to DNA script from the examples folder,
and I have pasted it in the script editor in a new Python window.
This has step-by-step instructions at the beginning.
To summarize the workflow for using this script, begin by loading the DNA file in a new Maya scene using the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
Then, save the current vertex and joint positions, make modifications to the neutral pose,
and once finished, set the new vertex and joint positions, and update the DNA file to include those changes.
To use the script, we will have to input the paths of the files we want to use.
If we scroll down to line 50, here we will input the name of the DNA file we are going to use.
If I go to the DNA files folder, this is the same name of the DNA file I want to use.
You can use Ada or Taro as those are already in the DNA files folder.
Next, we will need to specify the root directory where the DNA calibration repository is located.
In my case, it's in my C drive.
Something to note is that the backward slash needs to be replaced with a forward slash.
The output path is created through commands, and it will by default be named output.
This is where our modified DNA file will be saved.
Some of these paths we do not need to worry about as they are already set up for us,
such as the path of the DNA files folder and the analog GUI folder.
As mentioned earlier, if we wish to use the newer version of MetaHumans with the additional face controls,
we would change the path of the GUI and additional assembly script to point to those assets in the MH4 folder.
You would add MH4 forward slash here for the GUI, and then do the same for the assembly script path.
If you do not use the older version of MetaHuman, you can replace the GUI file
and the additional assembly script file from the MH4 folder with those in the main data folder
so that you do not have to keep updating the paths for these, which is what I have done.
This is the only input that is needed for this script.
Now, before we use this script, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
We can use the Propagate changes from Scene to DNA script to edit the neutral pose.
This script records the current vertex and joint positions for all meshes.
Once changes are made, it saves the delta between those two states and updates the DNA file.
The workflow is as follows.
First, run the commands that save the current vertex and joint positions of the head mesh.
Then, make modifications to the neutral mesh.
When finished, run the rest of the commands to set the new vertex and joint positions,
and then update the DNA file to include those changes.
For the script input, on line 50, enter the name of the DNA file you wish to edit.
For the root directory, enter the path that points to the DNA calibration folder
and make sure you use a forward slash.
Then, update the paths for the GUI and additional assembly script
to point to the MH4 folder if using the newer versions of MetaHumans.
Now that we have an idea of the workflow and what input we need to use,
in the next section we will go through executing the various commands and will edit the neutral pose.